because i feel like you have some kind
of spidey sense with singers like you
know i've seen you on
many shows and i think there's something
about you you can always kind of
recognize it whether it's one direction
all those guys are camille cabello me
there's so many i could name so many um
but what do you
what do you think you you catch that
maybe nobody else does
for me you can see it in people's eyes
you know it's like if you've got that
kind of
it's something when you look in in
someone's eyes when they audition
it you're like fearless and even if it's
not perfect there's
it's just something you recognize i mean
i wouldn't say get it right 100 percent
yeah but mostly you can write a lot i've
got a pretty good track record
and that's what i do i look in someone's
eyes and i can see whether they're
confident or not yeah and whether
they've got great taste
is another part of it yeah because a lot
of time people come on with the wrong
song choices song selection
why did you choose that song why didn't
you do something creative with it
i mean that's when i get frustrated but
look it's hard
but yeah it's still the most amazing
feeling you know
when you always remember that audition
when you meet the staff for the first
time
and that's you know genuinely why still
do the job now that's gotta be so cool
too that you see
um uh so young like i was 19. a lot of
those like one direction boys
really they were younger than that like
and then you see them now and they all
their separate careers they're all
that's just crazy amazing and camilla
was um
she wasn't even meant to audition she
wasn't um
i think we were like on time or
something that particular day which
meant she was a reserve
yeah and i went backstage to have a
cigarette and she was lying on the floor
crying
i went what's the matter she said they
won't let me audition i went well
just go and audition so she came out
five minutes later
amazing yep i'm still here just waiting
for you to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help